men are Evolutions play things you roll
the dice with them a little bit more
there's more genetic variations they're
kind of more disposable because as you
say it's women that set the upper Bound
in terms of procreation in a modern
world where women don't need to be
coddled so much anymore and yet we have
this mismatch now where the ability to
give sympathy to Men Who perhaps very
much need it isn't there it is
problematic in a modern environment for
multiple reasons not only that we can't
recognize men's suffering but also that
if we're more inclined to see women in
this like patient role this like
suffering victim role it makes us harder
for us to see them as agentic and so I
think this might contribute to why we
more easily recognize men as leaders and
so it's not always unilaterally positive
to see women as like the patient it can
be harmful when in the voting booth
you're not going to be recognized as an
agent and maybe not as a CEO but in the
context of moral harm you're not going
to be blamed to the same degree